bonjour le secrétaire général va vous
faire un point sur la réunion du conseil
otan russie et puis par la suite nous
aurons des questions ici en salle mais
également on va essayer pour certaines
questions en ligne sur le secrétaire
général
bonjour je viens de présider une réunion
du conseil otan russie à un moment
déterminant pour la sécurité européenne
ce n'était pas une discussion aisée mais
c'est justement la raison pour laquelle
cette réunion était si importante
nous avons mené un
échange tout à fait sérieux et direct
sur la situation en ukrainien
l'entourent et les implications que cela
a sur la sécurité européenne
il y a des différences majeures entre
les alliés de l'otan et la russie sur
ces questions
l'écart entre nos différents ce sera
difficile à combler mais il y à un signe
positif à savoir que tous les alliés de
l'otan et la russie se sont assis autour
de la même table et on interagit sur des
sujets majeurs
après deux ans où de telles réunions
n'était plus possible
aujourd'hui la russie a
proposé ou mis en avant les propositions
qu'elle avait publié en décembre et est
revenu sur ses préoccupations
sécuritaires cela incluait
c'est demande d'arrêter est d'admettre
de nouveaux membres au sein de l'otan et
retirer les forces
sur les territoires alliés les alliés de
leur côté ont
rappelé la politique de la porte ouverte
de l'otan et le droit de chaque pays à
décider de ses propres arrangements
sécuritaires des alliés ont été très
clairs à savoir qu'il n'allait pas
renoncer à leur capacité à se protéger
se défendre les uns des autres et cela
inclut avec la présence de troupes dans
la partie est de l'alliance
simultanément à la fois la russie et les
alliés de l'otan ont exprimé ces besoins
de reprendre le dialogue et d'explorer
un calendrier de réunions à venir
les alliés de l'otan sont prêts à se
réunir à nouveau avec la russie afin de
mener des débats et ceux dont plus de
détails afin de mettre sur la table des
propositions concrètes et d'essayer
d'obtenir des résultats constructifs et
notamment les alliés voudrait pouvoir
débattre de manière concrète d'augmenter
la transparence des exercices militaires
d'empêcher les incidents militaires
dangereux est également réduire les
menaces cyber et spatiale des alliés
également proposé d' examiner la
maîtrise des armements le désarmement et
la non prolifération
cela inclut la possibilité de revenir
sur des limites réciproques concernant
les missiles également de revenir sur
les politiques nucléaires
sur les lignes de communication les
alliés
sont intéressés par la possibilité de
voir comment améliorer les canaux de
communication civile et militaire est
également la possibilité de rétablir nos
différents bureaux à moscou et à
bruxelles
les alliés de l'otan sont lucides quant
aux perspectives d'avancer dans ces
pourparlers ils ont exprimé des
préoccupations graves quant au
renforcement militaire russe en ukraine
et alentours et on nous rappelait alors
réussi à se livrer à une désescalade
immédiate de cette situation ils
respectaient la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de ses voisins
ils ont également appelé la russie à
ne pas se livrer une posture de force
agressive et à toutes activités
dirigées contre les alliés et à
respecter toutes ces obligations et
engagements internationaux
cela signifie que tout ceci signifie que
notre dialogue est difficile mais encore
plus nécessaire les alliés de l'otan ont
souligné qu'ils se livraient à tous les
efforts nécessaires pour dégager une
issue politique
je me félicite également des
consultations bilatérales entre les
états unis la russie et la réunion
demain de l'ouest et il s'agit là d'
occasion pour une interaction
constructive qui ne
devrait pas être apte et ce pour servir
la sécurité en europe je suis prêt à
entendre vos questions cnn
merci monsieur leclerc général ces
discussions ont duré longtemps ce matin
pour quelles raisons les discussions
étaient elles aussi prolonger les alliés
ont rejeté la demande de l'otan
relatives à une éventuelle adhésion de
l'ukraine que la russie pardon relatives
à une éventuelle adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'otan mais est ce que vous connaissez
reconnaissez écrit ceci les démarches
des divergences de vue entre aller sur
ce sujet
réponse nous sommes concentrés sur les
discussions en ukraine et alentour et
des alliés ont fait part de leurs
préoccupations
relatives à la montée en puissance
militaire russe
près des frontières l'ukrainienne
la rhétorique la russie est agressive
la russie a de sérieuses en décédant la
matière donc
nous avons raison d'être inquiet et nous
restons lucides mais la réunion fut
utile lorsque les tensions sont fortes
il est d'autant plus important pour nous
de nous réunir tous nous asseoir autour
d'une même table pour débattre des
questions qui nous préoccupent
s'agissant des perspectives d'adhésion
et de la politique la porte ouverte de
l'otan tous les alliés sont d'accord sur
le principe fondamental selon lequel
chaque pays est libre de choisir
sa propre voie ce principe est inscrit
dans de nombreux documents qui
constituent le fondement même le socle
de la sécurité européenne
les alliés donc d'accord pour dire que
seule l'ukraine et les 30 alliés peuvent
décider si l'ukraine est prête ou non
devenir membre l'otan personne d'autre
n'a voix au chapitre il a réussi n'a pas
de droit de veto s'agissant d'une
éventuelle adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'otan les alliés sont prêts à soutenir
l'ukraine à mener à bien des réformes à
moderniser ses forces armées pour les
mettre en conformité avec les normes
otan mais in fine et il appartient aux
alliés et à l'ukraine de décider de son
éventuelle adhésion merci tu as
merci beaucoup de lagence d'as
monsieur le docteur général et
semblerait que vous ayez fait des
progrès léger dans le maine la réduction
des risques est ce que vous considérez
qui pourrait être envisageable à 9 à
l'avenir
d'introduire de nouvelles restrictions
sur la présence de systèmes de missiles
offensifs en europe
les alliés de l'otan ont indiqué dans la
réunion qu'ils étaient prêts à prévoir
un calendrier de réunions pour aborder
divers sujets dont les missiles avec des
restrictions
viable vérifiables pardon réciproque que
sur les systèmes de missiles en europe
la partie russe a fait savoir qu'elle
n'était pas prête à donner son accord
aujourd'hui
un tel calendrier de réunions je crois
que vous devriez demander à la partie
russe de préciser sa position
mais je suis heureux de dire qu'ils
étaient favorables un dialogue des
allées sont prêts à mettre sur la table
des propositions concrètes et à discuter
de la réduction des crises la
transparence la maîtrise des armements
et de restrictions
vérifiable sur les missiles mais
permettez moi d'ajouter que si micro
dans cette situation c'est parce que la
russie a enfreint le traité est finie
nous avions une interdiction nous avions
un traité qui a interdisez les missiles
à portée intermédiaire qui soit
conventionnel duo ou nucléaire c'était
l'une des pierres angulaires la maîtrise
des armements or la russie a déployé des
missiles en europe
et a bafoué les dispositions de ce
traité si nous nous retrouvons dans
cette situation c'est donc parce que le
traité qui a interdit tous les systèmes
du sida portée intermédiaire
a disparu ce traité n'est plus parce que
la russie l'a violé à maintes reprise en
installant des missiles contrairement
aux dispositions du traité alors que
nous sommes prêts à revenir à la table
des négociations nous sommes partisans
de la maîtrise des armements je sais qui
peut-être que possible de trouver des
accords mais alors il faudra des
restrictions équilibrait sur les
différents systèmes merci
bonjour
il semblerait que si la russie menacent
la sécurité urbaine aujourd'hui c'est
pour détourner l'attention de son non
respect du droit international
qui implique notamment l'occupation de
la grille mais l'occupation de certaines
régions on ne donne pas et une présence
militaire en moldavie et en géorgie je
voudrais vous demander si les alliés
sont unis sur ces dossiers est-ce qu'ils
vont
poursuivre leurs efforts en vue de
résoudre ses conflits
autres questions la russie exige des
garanties de la part de l'otan et des
états unis mais quelles garanties le
temps se traite l obtenir la russie en
matière de sécurité
la russie dispose de forces militaires
en géorgie en ukraine en crimée et en
république de moldova
ses forces sont présentes
sans le consentement des gouvernements
dans ces pays elles n'y ont jamais été
invitées elles ne sont pas les bienvenus
les alliés ont établi la russie a retiré
ses forces il ya respecter l'intégrité
territoriale et la souveraineté de la
géorgie l'ukraine et la république de
moldova
ce sont là des principes fondamentaux
les comptes hier de chaque pays peuvent
être respectées il en va de la sécurité
en europe le temps a entamé un dialogue
avec la russie mais ne l'ont pas
transiger sur le principe de base ne
l'ont pas transiger sur la souveraineté
et l'intégrité territoriale de tous les
payeurs bien et nous n'allons pas
transiger non plus sur le droit qu'ont
chaque pays de choisir le propre voie et
leurs propres engagements de sécurité et
nous n'allons pas non plus 30 10 et sur
le droit qu'ont les alliés de se
protéger et se défendre contre eux
aujourd'hui les alliés ont soulevé avec
la russie un grand nombre de questions
l'accent était mis sur l'ukraine et les
incidences la situation actuelle sur la
sécurité européenne
nous sommes préoccupés par la montée en
puissance militaire en ukraine et
alentour et 7 nuits en puissance se
poursuit
nous avons déjà vu ce genre de scénario
la russie a déjà recouru à la force à
l'encontre du vent pays et la russie a
également mené des cyberattaques contre
le pays nous avons vu le recours à des
armes chimiques sur un territoire urbain
et nous avons également
la russie sévir contre l'oppression
contre pardon l'opposition démocratique
en russie même l'otan participent au
dialogue en bonne foi nous sommes prêts
à discuter des questions de fond nous
sommes prêts à adresser à la russie des
propositions concrètes
mais en même temps nous devons
nous préparer à
ce que la russie
opte plutôt pour la confrontation nous
avons donc rappeler que tout recours à
la force à l'encontre de l'ukraine
constituerait une erreur stratégique
grave là par la russie et entraînerait
des conséquences graves la russie aura
payé un prix fort politique aux examens
merci beaucoup monsieur le secrétaire
général alors je me demandais si vous
pouviez nous dire si vous les alliés
avaient réagi
ces griefs historique de la russie quant
au rôle de la russie par exemple en
yougoslavie en libye est ce que vous
avez pu les rassurer on en disant que
l'otan n'est pas une menace chassant que
vous avez des personnes qui n existent
plus des leaders ont été enlevés du
pouvoir en partie grâce aux
interventions de l'otan alors l'otan est
une alliance défensive et j'amène
avons-nous par la force obliger un pays
à rejoindre notre alliance donc
l'élargissement de l'otan serait
agressif mais c'est pas du tout vrai
l'élargissement de l'otan a été une
pierre angulaire pour la démocratie et
la liberté en europe parce qu'elle est
partie des pays qui faisait partie de
l'union soviétique ou du pacte de
varsovie ils sont passés par des
processus indépendant démocratique et
c'est là qu'ils ont choisi de rejoindre
l'otan et beaucoup de ses alliés étaient
présents aujourd'hui dans la salle ils
ont dit justement cela à savoir qu' ils
sont ils ont rejoint l'otan parce qu'il
voulait faire partie d'une alliance
défensive qui garantissait la sécurité
et puis
plusieurs pays
qui font partie de l'ancienne
yougoslavie ont dit très clairement que
la yougoslavie s'est effondré non pas à
cause de l'otan
mais qu'il y avait des raisons internes
à cela expliquant cet effondrement
l'otan est intervenue bien plus tard et
ce fort d'un mandat des nations unies
pour mettre fin aux atrocités en bosnie
herzégovine donc toute cette idée que
l'otan a utilisé la force militaire pour
modifier les frontières d'un balcon
c'est faux et les frontières de
l'ancienne yougoslavie ont changé à
cause de raisons intérieures à
l'ancienne
yougoslavie et en appelle d'ailleurs
plusieurs pays le monténégro la croatie
la slovénie qui justement à la table on
dit cela et ils savent très bien que ce
n'était pas l'otan mais
plutôt des conflits internes au sein de
la yougoslavie qui ont abouti à cet
effondrement alors c'est vrai que l'otan
y est allé mais c'était pour mettre fin
aux atrocités protéger les personnes et
mettre fin notamment à ce qui s'est
passé à srebrenica
donc
c'est cela alors après sur la question
de la libye là c'était clairement un
mandat des nations unies je vous
rappellerai que au tout début
c'était en fait au départ une initiative
européenne
et puis après un certain temps les amis
européens ont demandé de l'aide à
l'automne puis l'otan est allé sur place
et appuyer les alliés européens dans le
cadre de leurs efforts en libye mais
c'était au départ un mandat des nations
unies la guitare tout
merci beaucoup
monsieur le secrétaire général j'aurais
de questions qui sont liées tout d'abord
vous avez dit qu'aujourd'hui la russie
n'a pas pu agréé un calendrier de
nouvelles réunions mais ce que vous avez
eu un engagement de principe à savoir
que les pourparlers dans ce cadre là
c'est à dire le mrc pourront continuer
donc ça c'est ma première question et
deuxième question
pour
finalement passer des discussions et des
pourparlers comme vous même vous les
avez décrit aujourd'hui
pour passer donc de cela aux
négociations est ce que la russie
devrait pour ce faire mené 7 désescalade
comme condition préalable du point de
vue des alliés c'est de retirer les
troupes avant que des négociations
puissent commencer
j'ai proposé quelque chose les aliments
d'appuyer il sert est-à-dire l'idée
d'avoir tout un ensemble de réunions qui
permettent d'aborder tout un ensemble de
questions la maîtrise armement les
missiles la réduction du risque et
cetera
voilà donc ça tout le monde est content
donc la russie n'était pas en mesure d'
agressive proposition ils n'ont pas
rejeté non plus mais les représentants
russes ont dit clairement qu'ils avaient
besoin de temps pour fournir à l'otan
une réponse est bien évidemment
nous sommes prêts à nous asseoir à la
même table
et donc nous sommes prêts à le faire et
nous espérons que la russie sera
d'accord à se lancer dans toute une
série de réunions pour aborder ces
questions et j'espère que la réponse de
la russie sera positive parce que le
dialogue les pourparlers ces deux
tournois c'est ce dont on a besoin dans
différents formats nous nous réjouissons
des débats bilatéraux des états unis la
russie sur des questions stratégiques de
los feliz temps de la réunion qui va
avoir lieu à l'oif demain et le conseil
otan russie est également et dans cette
importante
je soulignerai également que nous sommes
très reconnaissants
ces consultations rapprocher convoi
entre alliés et notamment le fait que
les états unis ont consulté les alliés à
la fois avant leurs pourparlers
bilatéraux avec la russie à genève mais
également par la suite et que wendy
sherman ait pu passer autant de temps
avec les alliés de l'otan a mené ses
consultations rapprocher ça démontre
bien que l'otan est une plateforme tout
à fait unique pour réunir les alliés
européens et d'amérique du nord pour
aborder les préoccupations sécuritaires
nous sommes prêts à nous asseoir à cette
table est bien évidemment pour
enregistré de réelles avancées et faire
la différence il faut qu'ils aient
c'était des escalades mais nous avons
dit très clairement que nous étions
prêts à nous réunir dès à présent on
s'est réuni aujourd'hui et de le faire
dans un avenir proche pour pouvoir
continuer d'aborder les différentes
questions non plus de détails de manière
plus spécifique
rossi a one
alors vous avez parlé de la désescalade
et des troupes russes sur le territoire
russe est ce que vous pensez vraiment
que de nouveaux exercices militaires et
le fait d'envoyer des armes à l'ukraine
ce qui ne fait pas partie
du territoire alliés est ce que vous
pensez franchement que cela ait de la
désescalade
l'ukraine est un pays s'ouvre à lui
crête a le droit de s'auto défendre et
l'ukraine n'est pas une menace
pour la russie
la russie
la force terrestre la plus grande en
europe c'est l'une des principales
puissances nucléaires
la russie a beaucoup investi dans de
nouvelles capacités modernes ces
dernières années mais pas seulement cela
l'a réussi à utiliser la force militaire
contre l'ukraine et ce de par le passé
en 2014 ils ont occupé et pris une
partie de l'ukraine la crimée ils ont
ils continuent d'occuper illégalement
et la russie contrôle par le biais
des séparatistes le donbass donc ici
présenter les choses ainsi c'est
présenter les choses à l'envers c'est la
russie qui est l'agresseur c'est la
russie qui a utilisé la force continue
de l'utiliser contre l'ukraine et après
ils ont ce renforcement avec environ
100000 troupes d'artillerie les blindés
des drones des dizaines de milliers de
troupes prêtes au combat et avec un
discours menaçant alors bien évidemment
c'est ça le problème
cette crise
elles étaient fabriquées par la russie
donc il est important que eux se livrent
à la désescalade l'ukraine a le droit de
s'auto défendre cela se retrouve
d'ailleurs dans la charte des nations
unies et bien évidemment les alliés de
l'otan et l'otan les aident à préserver
ce droit à l'autodéfense le new york
times
merci
monsieur le secrétaire général
une question quant à cette suggestion
que en l'état actuel des choses l'otan
est prête à renforcer les troupes
alliées qui sont à la frontière de la
russie
que la russie se rendent en ukraine ou
non est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire si
peut-être cela a été évoqué lors de la
réunion
peut-être comme
un signal d'alerté en donner à la russie
alors peut-être que ma mémoire me fait
défaut mais je crois que l'otan est allé
au kosovo sans résolution des nations
unies mais ayez talent et après la une
guerre avec une résolution des nations
unies
alors tout d'abord toute cette idée que
l'effondrement de la yougoslavie a été
causée par l'otan c'est c'est faux vous
pouvez étudier toute l'histoire la
yougoslavie et là vous verrez clairement
qui avait aucun soldat de l'otan sur
place
ils sont arrivés des années plus tard et
on est allé pour mettre fin aux
atrocités
et ça c'était le cas c'était des guerres
sanglantes c'était le cas en bosnie et
au kosovo après des années de tentatives
avortées de trouver une solution donc il
était nécessaire d'aller sur place de
garantir un soutien pour
mettre fin à ces atrocités au kosovo
également mais à ce moment là la
yougoslavie s'était déjà effondrée et
votre première question
[Musique]
la question du renforcement
alors
on fera toujours ce qui est nécessaire
pour protéger défendre tous les alliés
est constamment nous évaluons la
nécessité d'ajuster notre présence dans
différentes parties de l'alliance
après d'un expert légal de la russie de
la crimée par la russie en 2014 et la
déstabilisation continue dans la partie
est de l'ukraine et le donbass nous
avons mis en oeuvre un renforcement de
notre défense collective
le plus grand renforcement d'ailleurs
avec des groupements tactiques dans la
partie est de l'alliance avec des forces
au niveau de préparation et également
avec une multiplication par trois de la
taille de la nrf la police du ciel
davantage de présence également donc
nous le faisons pour essayer d'éviter
tout malentendu et ne perçaient
permettre aucun espace de mauvais
calculs à savoir que finalement l'otan
est là pour protéger ses alliés c'est la
dissuasion c'est défensif et l'objectif
c'est de préserver la paix ce n'est pas
de provoquer le conflit c'est de
préserver la paix est d'empêcher le
conflit est bien évidemment si la russie
une nouvelle fois entend utiliser la
force contre l'ukraine et continuent
d'envahir l'ukraine alors il va falloir
avec sérieux envisager la nécessité de
renforcer notre présence dans la partie
est de l'alliance
merci monsieur le docteur générale
hier
l'ambassadrice américaine
arrêtée elle ce que vous me dire à
savoir que la politique de la porte
ouverte de l'otan est intangible
est ce que vous pensez qu'il est plus ou
moins
probable que l'on puisse éviter une
escalade
sans remettre cette politique en
question est ce qu'il est possible est
ce qu'il est possible d'aller plus
il sera possible d'aller plus loin si la
russie est prête à négocier et à trouver
une solution politique
nous sommes prêts à discuter d'une vaste
série de questions dont la maîtrise des
armements et qu'il y prête en
conventionnel nucléaire la réduction des
risques la transparence des mesures de
confiance et ces mécanismes ont déjà
fait leurs preuves par le passé mais
nous ne sommes pas prêts à remettre en
cause la des principes fondateurs la
sécurité européenne à savoir que chaque
pays est libre de choisir sa propre voie
et il est intéressant de constater que
des pays tels que la finlande et la
suède qui ne sont pas candidate à
l'adhésion de l'otan sont très clairs là
dessus
parce que c'est payé savent que dès que
l'on impose ce genre de restrictions dès
que l'on commence à dire que seuls
certains pays ont le droit de choisir
librement leur voix cela revient à créer
une europe à deux vitesses certains pays
auraient droit au libre choix parce
qu'ils sont grands ou parce qu'ils sont
membres historiques de l'otan d'autres
pays ne jouirait pas de ce même droit
cette idée selon laquelle
les pays
proches
de certains autres pays n'aurait pas
tous les droits revient à recréer des
spermatozoïdes lui ans ceux qui viennent
des petits pays limitrophes la russie
comprennent à quel point ce chemin et
période et c'est la raison pour laquelle
le président de femmes hand dans son
discours du 1er janvier a rappelé
l'importance de ce principe alors même
qu'ils sont payés n'est pas candidat à
l'adhésion à l'otan
il faut opérer une distinction
entre d'une part
les principes les règles du droit
international
et d'autre part
la réalité et la possibilité pour
l'ukraine d' adhérer rapidement a le
temps alors sommes nous prêts à
transiger sur les principes de base nous
sommes nous prêts à discuter en bonne
foi
de la maîtrise des armements de mesures
pour une science la transparence lui
prêt à écouter les préoccupations russes
celle là la réponse est oui
une question par vtc je donne ma parole
au washington post
merci beaucoup
il semblerait que nous soyons encore
dans l'impasse
les deux parties campent sur leurs
positions
alors comment éviter ce genre de
discussions à l'avenir sommes lula dans
une spirale dans un processus
interminable
je ne pense pas que ces discussions
seront interminables
pour sortir de cette crise il suffit à
la russie de procéder à une désescalade
si nous sommes d'ici si nous connaissons
la crise actuelle c'est parce que la
russie a renforcé sa présence militaire
en ukraine et alentour et que ce
renforcement a été accompagnée d'un
discours agressif
selon lequel
des mesures militaro technique serait
prise à moins que ces conditions ne soit
acceptée donc pour désamorcer les
tensions actuelles il suffit
de procéder à une désescalade
plus globalement je rappelle que le
temps à une approche double vis-à-vis de
l'otan nous devons rester fermes unis
solidaires et nous le sommes en tant
qu'allié mais nous devons en même temps
reste est prêt à participer à un
dialogue substantiel avec la russie la
russie et notre voisine nous devons nous
retrouver pour discuter de nos
préoccupations de ses crottes et
ensemble et nous l'avons déjà fait par
le passé nous avons conclu des accords
sur la maîtrise des armements après la
fin de la guerre froide nous avons fait
de grands progrès ensemble cette voie
reste ouverte à la russie nous appelons
la russie à choisir cette voie de la
diplomatie du dialogue la désescalade
plutôt que la confrontation
merci rien
monsieur leclerc général bonjour
à quel moment
pensez vous que des progrès seront
accomplis dans la réouverture la mission
russe auprès du siège de l'otan et yat
il des conditions préalables à réunir
s'agissant de la réouverture de solution
ni aucune condition préalable
nous regrettons la décision par la
russie de fermait sa mission
diplomatique vis-à-vis de l'otan et nous
regrettons également la fermeture par la
russie du bureau l'otan à moscou mais
nous avons nous dit lors la réunion du
matin nous souhaitons couvrir et le
bureau de l'otan à moscou et la mission
russe auprès de l'otan parce que nous
sommes partisans du dialogue parce que
nous croyons que c'est bureau c'est
diplomates font partie intégrante des
infrastructures n'ont besoin pour mener
un dialogue consistant que ses bureaux
soit rouvert ou pas nous avons la ferme
conviction que si la russie est prête à
participer à une série de réunions sur
un éventail de questions
nous pouvons être prêt à préparer ces
discussions grâce à des pourparlers si
vous louez tard préparatoire pour ses
réunions
soit
consistante
cette tâche sera simplifiée si les deux
bureaux mentionnait son goût vert mais
nous pourrons faire ce travail même sans
ses différents bureaux
merci
bonjour vous avez dit que si c'est
discussions venaient à échouer le temps
serait prête à nouveau confirmée vous
avez assisté aux discussions de ce matin
quel est votre sentiment sommes-nous
proche d'un nouveau confirmé le risque
d'un nouveau conflit armé en europe est
réel
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
réunion et d autres réunions prévues
cette semaine sont aussi importante
parce que nous allons faire tout notre
possible pour éviter un nouveau conflit
armé c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
indiquons clairement à la russie que
nous sommes prêts à nous asseoir autour
d'une table pour discuter d'une série de
questions m usd renommant restrictions
sur les missiles pour justement prévenir
un nouveau gouverneur mais en même temps
nous restons lucides nous faisons valoir
également à la russie que si elle
recours à la force militaire il y aura
des conséquences graves des sanctions
économiques politiques sont encourus
nous apportons un soutien pratique à
l'ukraine pour renforcer sa capacité à
se défendre les alliés s'ils prennent
par différents moyens il est également
important de comprendre que l'ukraine
est un pays partenaire nous lui offrons
un soutien politique et pratique sous
différentes formes mais le temps n'est
pas mon l'ukraine perde on n'est pas
membre le temps et donc les garanties de
sécurité l'article sags un pour tous
tous pour un ne s'applique qu'aux seuls
membres de l'otan et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons dit sans
ambages que nous ferons tout notre
possible pour protéger tous les alliés
une attaque contre un allié suscitera
une réponse de la part de l'alliance
tout entière je crois qu'il est
dangereux de se livrer à des conjectures
il y à un risque réel
nous et réagissons en participant à un
dialogue de bonne foi mais aussi en
restant lucide merci se situe place
monsieur le secrétaire général le
président poutine avait un accord ou un
projet d'accord qu'il voulait débattre
avec l'otan est ce que la délégation
russe a mises d'accord sur la table vous
avez rejeté les principes noyau de cela
donc du coup ça a été totalement écartée
la russie
a mis en avant cette proposition de
traiter sur la table
les loyers aux états unis à l'otan
mais bien évidemment ces propositions
ont été présentées aussi à la réunion
d'aujourd'hui et
essayer de défendre ses propositions les
alliés ont dit très clairement qu'ils
étaient ouverts au dialogue on peut
débattre de beaucoup de questions mais
on ne peut pas débattre de principes
fondamentaux comme par exemple la
liberté de choisir votre propre
cheminement notamment en termes
d'arrangement sécuritaire
ce à quoi certains pays d'europe veulent
participer et de défendre tous les
alliés notamment les alliés à l'est mais
là à nouveau mais il est possible de se
mettre d'accord sur maîtrise des
armements vérifiables quelque chose qui
soit équilibrée
sur les missiles tout ce qui est
conventionnel tout ce qui est nucléaire
tous les autres domaines et ça on l'a
dit aussi très clairement je vous
remercie nous en avons terminé que cette
conférence de presse merci beaucoup